welcome to this 15-minute game playing
accepted benign and have played him
before i'm pretty sure not too long ago
let's see an English opening and English
opening and French opening I was just
writing something about the English and
somehow had this still in my mind ok so
the win over french click Knight c3 it
for change yeah ok a 3 is normal but
maybe try something else the Sun this
Bishop t2 line is some somewhat
forgotten but it's not not a terribly
bad choice it's very solid black does
not have any great problems but still
it's quite um ok pianos to theory on as
I found a book night age six is a good
response in tending Knight to f5 in any
case white is always playing nice and
five him to to get them this exchanged
the dark squared bishop ok so I go see
3m gold star the center yeah I wonder do
I do a half of the time to play a four
or is this too slow now that it looks
very slow
hmm
y an idea three is got f6 yeah not not
so great really okay maybe I need to
invest this time interesting i think i
take with the night or or not hmm i take
with the pawn I have Knight c3 as a good
retreat but he really quickly can attack
my mighty poem so I think this is um
maybe the most solid way to play moon
yeah I'm not well developed light f3f e5
Knight takes c6 and ninety xe5 is that
f7 at the end mmm that's not a terribly
great position that I have him night f7
was also fine for black
hmm not really good
yeah that's really not great and I mean
he probably can even play Knight f7 here
and just lets us epon came didn't do
that I couldn't be 6 not a bad move
now black blanket son in excellent shape
here can always exchange my mine idea
only five with night f7 he has a good
center and rupee aid attacking be too
yeah that's not that's not great really
yeah maybe I need to to Castle long here
yeah I do I really don't want to but
maybe I must must do that then I don't
want to cancel long simply getting right
into the B file
ok shall adjust retreat out to f3 jelly
what I really want to do is to get to
get the Queen's of your queen f2
something like that yeah maybe i can get
it get it exchanged him if he is not
playing them he plays c5 i can at least
castle short maybe queen age 4 is also
an idea so i can exchange queen so that
that's in general good news let's let's
do that ok I force hanging so I got on
plane g3 I guess now he's got push up a
sixer
he can just play Bishop a six
that'sthat's really just good getting
the lightscribe bishops trade it I can
play Bishop see to actually moon now
came Bishop C toon Oh interesting it's a
bit of a weird move why is it going I
can also take yeah but why take out I
can always take this piece of I want and
my bishop is just wrong on d3 i'll
rather play rookie 195 those kind of
those kind of moves you see threatening
something c4 I can take so just play the
move I want to play rook e1 if he goes
Bishop BB 70 I go 95 double attacking
the H poor 96 yeah now I seem to gain
control now over the position c4 here c4
is interesting
maybe 95 first it's not easy also also
see far as interesting see 496 maybe
look see one threatening see your form
yeah this is threatening see form now
that's not doing so much okay maybe if I
go see four he takes takes Bishop Jake's
can also just take with the pawn after
that okay anyway let's let's do this get
the h-bomb out of them out of the fire
now c4 is still possible
ok
997 now whoopsie six okay maybe like
this if he goes d4 i have ninety-seven
and this will win the c5 porn at the end
I'm threatening to take and take c5 so
it's difficult now for him the main
problem now is that all my pieces are
better than his Brooke age 6 mm but I
take t5m the after Luke c5 there's a
checkmate threat can also take first a
less no check my thread CA discovered of
course nonsense but it it's still in the
position like rugby 3 rugby one for
instance yeah that's in fact strong
hooker p3 rupee one is winning outright
I believe yeah NTM take it or look a one
who k 1 is also not bad but okay let's
let's take this take this first if i
play rook a one now how do you cover the
68 mate
the night moves that there is there is
the matin and rugby 78 ak-74 Roxy a
checkmate
hmm this was a very shaky position right
of the right out of the opening night h6
awesome really am really inconvenient
line I mean I am I'm not the neck back
Riley not an expert and I lost too much
too much time yeah here there is no way
to prevent this let's let's have a look
at this this position right in the
opening I know that this is a move but I
don't know how it is exactly it laid out
i mean this chassis's it costs lots of
time maybe the captions if i have him i
don't know i mean this this yeah this is
really really slow the sun is kind of
plane here i actually thought that maybe
he could play a 6 first or or queen bee
six but what he did was totally okay
certainly and now i have six here Nadia
three any to get some stuff developed
and Tia wats night f7 was an interesting
just increasing the pressure only five
probably need to take now and this is a
big sin time something like that is
certain defined for black
it could be six or seven reserved okay
yeah maybe I should casts a long ready
but I didn't I didn't want to do that if
I do this now let's check there's ruka
for no it's the rookie form or something
like that yeah Queen takes a maid but I
have this reply maybe not i'm not
totally convinced by all this night f7
year and now him TM my development I
went back ya hear e5 is an interesting
move opening up the position something
like that yeah that looks looks very
nice actually for black yeah I don't
have any development but ok what he did
wasn't bad I think and now taking and e5
was good again yeah like has a very good
musician yeah but but this is just
giving me the edge again because of my
better structure I've got to pawn
islands against three and this is this
is somewhat better provide yeah now he
played some move that didn't really lead
to anything night be five I don't mind
to play this year all this is improving
my position and this this rook is really
on its way to being totally offside here
see for was already possible but this is
just wrong ya know c4 as strong or 95
first it it's it's just just both good
yeah here you cannot do anything like
that anymore
this was what I had calculated winning a
material and after that is also also
winning huge chunks of material yeah and
here the the main threat on 1c8 decides
just like just like that checkmate with
a funny mate at the end still a shaky
game this opening didn't really either
went well didn't really go well okay
thanks for watching